okay welcome to the first installment of
reinventing the workshop in this
academic year ever since formulating
this series we have anticipated Ariana's
contribution to this conversation that
is dedicated to the reworking reframing
and reshaping of the status quo of the
American workshop as her work continues
to defy existing laws in all of the
poetic dimensions from composition to
form to performance and beyond
how will a poet who when describing the
writing of her book York be reinstated
the structure is the most important
thing about the book the structure is
its justice apply our expansive
understanding to an institution that is
the underlying structure of creative
writing pedagogy in this country and
which in this speakers mind is so
overdue for a revision I have no idea
but I welcome you here tonight to find
out ariana Raines was born in Salem
Massachusetts her books include the cow
cordially oh mercury
Thursday and the origin of the world
written for Senate Oakes semi Oh texts
contribution to the 2014 Whitney
Biennial her first play telephone
inspired by a Beatle Nels the telephone
book was commissioned and produced by
the foundry Theater winning two obese
performances of theatrical works include
Mortal Kombat the origin of the world
Lorna miss miss Saints hieroglyphic
suffering starring Burchett topic at the
Solomon R Guggenheim Museum and
swiftness at the Swiss
to other projects include the opening of
the mouth
a silence based Vision Quest for artists
and radicals in New Mexico organized
with Bette Williams and ancient evenings
a weekly experiment in writing and
liturgical reading reigns is also a
licensed astrologer offering Marguerite
hard-ass birth chart sessions at her
studio astrology Queens and just a quick
note there are handouts but there are
not enough for everyone so please share
with your neighbor I'm a traveler and
I'm already feeling separation I get to
hear your voices I am very excited to be
here it's really roomy in this room and
and I'm I'm here to tell you about a
project that came out of a lot of a
combination of a lot of different things
not just a fatigue with with creative
writing petticoat because I'll explain I
actually don't have I didn't have all
that much experience with
either as a teacher or as a student when
one agency came about so the way things
are going to go this evening I'm sorry
that I can't get you all the drunk
that's a big renovation evenings
actually as with all sabes some kind of
intoxication usually just the text
itself and the sound of the voices and
the kind of breathlessness that comes
from having to do a lot of reading the
lab is enough I don't know if you've
ever tried to play woodwind instrument
if you're you know for the first time
but it makes it really dizzy
I tried to play the flute for like a
teenager
gave me head restrooms so yeah you don't
need we don't need alcohol we're just
going to use our voices so I would love
it if I know that there's a lot of us
but but if if you could just say your
name and and I would love to know if
you're a student here or or somebody who
lives around here or or you could tell
me kind of anything I want to get your
name and like one sentence does anything
so that actually I can try to meet us
there like maybe we can start at you
thank you I'm Luis and I'm not a student
I'm Kevin and I live in Cambridge not a
student so I'm sorry
we can go through the back and then come
back okay America I live in the suburbs
and I'm not a student here I'm Chloe I'm
the associate curator of the room here
and that's to me I'm Mary I work here in
the poetry remind you audio preservation
work with the archives Simona I grew up
near here then I went to UC Berkeley and
I'm visiting for the year
and you're what posting them oh great
I live in Dorchester hi I'm Jim tonight
i'm suzanne mercury poet live nearby now
a student here I'm Marc I'm Erin I'm a
senior I'm Stephanie I'm sitting here
I'm God I'm a senior here but my family
lives in the erotic
I'm Nick and I am teacher I'm Kat I'm
studying English to finish my first
translation project here so about be
done because you what from German to
English I'm Cheryl
i'm eugene from my team and
like a creative med Sciences a creative
mad time great there's one chair
and I'm here because I lost my when
they would anyone
thank you I love hearing of your voices
and so it's like visually fatigue that I
went sorry for the sounds of of people's
voices I don't know so I really really
appreciate it and now I can try to
explain what I what I want to do I'm
gonna try to tell you like a personal
story about why I made up this thing
ancient you things because I needed it
very very badly in my in my life for
lots of very personal reasons and and
it's something that I tried I was trying
to figure out a way to like expropriate
the feel the the need that I felt and
turn it into something that could be
hospitable so that I wouldn't be alone
in either the pursuit or the longing and
so that so that I could see what it
would be like to try to make something
around a kind of world of feeling that
otherwise felt like really pushed into
the negative of life I know I'm speaking
kind of abstractly but it's because I'm
like reading myself up to speak really
personally about about how this all came
together so I knew some pictures and a
PowerPoint which I've never done before
successfully I've had a lot of
PowerPoint crash and burn like this
micro semis
and so I'm gonna start a tiny story of
how this came about it that's that can
and and then we will read some of this
Sumerian sequence to two poems from
Stevens of Palms to the goddess Alana
that are that form a narrative of her of
her life story recognize this symbol
that is the International pawnshop
symbol and it originated in I think
before like earlier than Renaissance
Italy that it's an Italian it's an
Italian thing and I have I found a lot
of things in my life and I I made this
I made this kind of test flag as a kind
of a half joke so it says swab with do
to achieve with us yet it's like a it's
like a maybe a snarky or a lame play on
Aleppo who are delete wretch who were no
I'm pretending I can't speak French
protest yell
so I I one of the ways that I was
thinking about ancient evenings was a
kind of ransacking of the theological
archive of the world which now is
available for free on the internet i I
before 2012 another thing sort of a slow
build from like birth up to 2012 like
Anna scatological
and apocalyptic depression had been
building up in me and to the point where
I started to realize that it was like a
it was like a some kind of secretion
like every day like the dread was like a
liquid that would like fill me up as the
day went and I'm like I'd have to do
something to make the level go back down
again but it was just this like physical
mounting thing in my life and um you
know during the Bush years it was
especially strong everyone everyone was
talking about the end of the world and
the apocalypse it was like it became
this finality and but it was also we
were also kind of like drenched in
something like a weird burlesque of
religion in this country I think that's
how I felt about it and and and so I
thought the pond symbol was was ideal
for this project not only because of my
own relationship to bad economics and
brokenness and scheisse tourism and all
that sort of thing but because I think
the banking crisis and the financial
structure of not just finance in this
country but international finance is
pretty much operating on a very similar
principle as as some come as a sort of
dishonest pawnbroking situation where
you get fleeced and for me and my
experience of the university was a bit
of
thing but I'll bracket that and maybe
come back to it when I put this all
together so um this came about this idea
ancient evenings
Akim it came about after occupy after
some experiences teaching both inside
and outside the Academy after some real
hardcore experiences of destitution and
homelessness also bearing witness to
destitution and homelessness on the part
of people that I loved and people in my
family and also being a witness to
suicide all that sort of thing was
coming into this the other really big
catalyst I suppose for this project was
the earthquake in Haiti and there's it's
this is something that's really
difficult to write about and to talk
about but on January 12 2010 the world
was convulsed into a relation to Haiti
by way of its earthquake that I feel was
an electric and shocking experience
because I grew up in Massachusetts and I
know that some of you in this room also
did I grew up hearing the phrase the
shot heard round the world is that
familiar yeah and and I thought a lot I
became I started to think very very hard
about how long it takes a revolution to
arrive or how long
takes for the world to hear a shot and
it seems to me that the Haitian
Revolution had been occulted by the
world for a very very long time and that
this eruption and this horrifying trauma
was was was a way of an extreme delay of
a shot being heard and it it affected me
I would say that I had affected me in a
kind of nineteenth-century stereo kind
of quiet just to explain where I was at
the time I was living in Los Angeles
with a person who in a miserable
relationship and I had just had play
produced in New York and a performance
of Guggenheim and I just thought as per
semester at Berkeley and had a wonderful
time and turned down an offer for a job
because I was afraid that if I took this
job I I would become a scatological
schizophrenic and what do I mean by that
I think that I was a person who had a
lot of trauma and so when something good
was offered to me it terrified me I
could only I could only feel completely
unworthy and I was afraid that if I if I
took this opportunity that I would
become crazy and that I would I would
try to perform outwardly while inwardly
finding ways to punish my
you feel terrible and I don't know if
any of you here at Harvard have know
people like that around an experience of
that in yourselves but I in my lifetime
knowing knowing people who are survivors
of terrible things or who who have borne
witness to - or horror on the part of
others there's often a lot of survivor's
guilt and and for me I always felt like
I was kind of living through the
Holocaust like that was that was my
delusion
that's the delusion that my first book
was made of so when when the Haiti
earthquake happened I was in a very very
strange and kind of open state and uh uh
well I I responded hysterically and I
bluffed my way onto a UN outreach trauma
outreach team as a translator even
though I'm fluent in French not Creole
but the the team of people were ignorant
enough to think that French and Creole
are the same or almost really you know
just about the same language and so they
took me on and I had no business being
there I had no training and no no reason
no right to be there I was again I was
there for historical reasons but also I
think for religious reasons and it's
hard to it's hard to
it's hard to explain but there it is
what is what I felt when I was there was
that it was I was I was inside a kind of
Mondial bed or an upside-down world I I
had been like a kind of lazy medievalist
and one of one of the kind of tropes of
medieval literature is this is the way
is that and also medieval cultural
practice like the massive tools the ways
that they would invert or reverse the
power structure of their world either in
in fabulous or in Festival in
celebration and it felt like it really
felt like the geologically a huge
accretion of colonial had been just
shaken off what by an animal and it was
electrifying and there was the sense
that things might change and that a
revolution might arrive and this
graffiti is is calling for the return of
heiress deed which now has happened and
but of course he has a right wing
president who's associated with the the
Duvalier rest regime and I won't go in
too much to Haitian politics because
that's really not exactly what we're
here to talk about the point is it was
it was a rupture it was a moment of
opening and it made me think and made me
feel that I had to reverse or invert the
power structure organizing everything
that I did in life I am
I went back a second time I convinced
this the artist Jorge Cardenal only his
airplane and pilot which I filled with
tents it was a completely absurd thing
I'm just trying to show how how foolish
how foolish I was and yet I was I was
foolish and convincing and it was a it
was a moment that a lot of people were
giving vent to their foolishness and
their compassion and paying attention to
a place that they had basically raped
sucked dry and ignored for 200 years and
so it's a strange moment a strange
moment of mass outpouring of what seems
to be and often was genuine completely
impassioned hysterical generosity when
he came back from Haiti and became a
fervent student of the Haitian
Revolution and and a kind of hysterical
student of revolution itself I I became
really really depressed and I was
getting these spamming emails I think
I've had some trolls and some creepy
stalkers and some really really mean of
users who actually made me feel really
bad about myself with their mean
messages one of them said my favorite
one was um one guy called me a Marie
Antoinette of the soul Marie Antoinette
of the soul and I I don't know I thought
there was something
amazing but anyway I was feeling really
bad and then one day I got this kind of
spammy email that was dressed me and
Bobby tal Rennell the philosopher and I
don't I didn't know the person I think
he maybe because we have the same
initials or something he just was just
like sent us this weird long letter and
it was been the subject line was
something about rabbi Rimes and I
thought this was like a mean joke
because I was so used to being abused by
strangers I got some nice letters too
but I'm not the kind of person to pay
attention to nice letters I will be
fixated on the mean ones enim I looked
into this rabbi Rhymes and he was a
zionist rabbi and yeshiva leader in
Belarus who was very very very very
clear about the immorality of taking
land from what he called the Ishmaelites
the Palestinians by force he said to
shed a single drop of Ishmaelite blood
would be would would basically destroy
the Jewish people and that that we that
he advocated buying land from them and
he was an early Zionists he was also a
really progressive pedagogue he his
yeshiva was the first one or one of the
first from what I would I believe from
various googling adventures it was the
first you she would teach subjects other
than the Torah and the Talmud so he was
trying to he was touching mathematics he
was teaching history he was teaching
philosophy and this was seen as
extremely
Stream Li radical and so this was like
the most electrifying piece of spam I
ever received because I have a really
bad relationship with my father and I I
don't really have in my family men I can
look up to at all they're all they're
all kind of horrifying and and I hadn't
realized how how badly I wanted to have
some kind of patriarchy that I could
feel good about and I don't even talk to
my father go but I found out about rabbi
rise I wrote him a letter and I was like
dear dad no we haven't spoken in 10
years and I know we disagree on a lot of
things but I just found out that this
amazing person this rabbi Grimes who was
a Zionist between mokuba's completely
against any any bloodshed against
against people and and cou and who was a
progressive but a sage and a scholar I
think we could be related I mean look at
his eyes I think he kind of looks like I
think he could it could be this could be
something and I thought this could heal
my relationship with my father and and
maybe maybe it could help me to discover
my vocation you know it helped me to to
unify all the different longings that
that have me running around the world
like an hysteric and and desperately
trying to study revolution while being a
crazy poet and and a bad lady
homeless person I mean what was I don't
know it I was doing or trying to build
all I know is I was desperately trying
to integrate things but my dad wrote
back and said
we weren't related to grab my rhymes and
so I just decided that I'm not related
to my dad because obviously I like
Jessica like anyway so that was a really
hard hard period like late 2010 into and
through 2011 but in the fall of 2011
Occupy happened and it it there was so
much sorrow right before that began it
was like this physical pressure in New
York City where I live the the 10th
anniversary of 9/11 hit me really
strangely like I thought I knew how I
felt about it yeah I thought I'd known
exactly how I felt about it the whole
time but I was crying in the
street that day and a lot of people burn
and there was something about that the
sorrow that felt like I've been hating
everyone and myself for 10 years because
we let this horror happen on top of us
and in our name and and even though we
all know it's somehow not our fault we
all blame ourselves and we all hate each
other a little bit for having let this
happen to our country to our culture and
to the world there was this like release
of sorrow and the horror of the Troy
Davis execution which felt like a public
beheading all of that for me those two
things were what wanted to occupy was
this gigantic release of sorrow in
public space that's what it meant to me
I meant a lot of meant a lot of other
things
something opened up again and it was
kind of like that earthquake I mean not
like that earthquake but it was it was a
it was a moment where the impossible was
in charge instead of all the other
that we serve day in and day
out and when with a friend in New Mexico
I put together a kind of week-long
experiment called the opening of the
mouth and that the title of that is a
ripoff
from a ceremony that's done that was
done in ancient Egypt during the
mummification process so after all the
organs have been drained out of the body
and after it had been anointed and and
various chemical processes had been
applied and or preserved the body there
would be there was a there was a
ceremony that that would allow the the
person the dead person to eat and talk
and live on in the afterlife and I was
trying to work out some kind of relation
to authentic speech I was trying to work
out a fantasy also an authentic speech
and in relation to let's say like
artistic or poetic speech I was trying
to find some connect
between the in the maybe the intimacy of
poetic address and the urgency of the
people's might and that's a completely
ridiculous delusional ambition what it
consisted of was about ten people
gathering in a house in New Mexico and
not talking for the first ten hours or
something and the idea of trying to use
silence instead of talk was to see if we
could get to something to some other
kind of communication that if we could
remove the the ways that we use language
to normalize ourselves in relation to
each other that we might be able to get
we might that we might be able to go
from zero to sixty faster if we removed
the like hello were you from type of
language I don't remember yeah I broke
the mallet I'm sure I'm sure it's very
in there I'm Jackie was there
that's right you did and there was a
fire burning yeah yeah lots of stage
there were ways that this was a little
bit full of healing because you know a
lot of us were were traumatized by
police brutality in the violent breakup
of Occupy and there were a lot of other
things intervening on that moment I also
had a miscarriage really shortly after
that so it was a very very strange
sequence of events then I ended up back
of Haiti I had been ripped into working
Ana mobile naturopathic clinic run by a
Haitian born Tibetan hunt and I'm not a
naturopath so again I was doing work for
which I am not qualified fascinating
work in kind of crazy ad-hoc
circumstances this is under an orphanage
so we were working and all kinds of
strange little corners in order to
provide plant medicine care to people
and it was an extremely beautiful and
difficult disorienting circumstance
which also tested my my sense of belief
in disbelief like I don't know if any of
you are into homeopathy anyone is
interested
yeah so it's like there's like this way
that it seems come amazing and then
there's this other way that it seems so
it seems it's like almost like magic or
like mumbo-jumbo
like it's like on the phone it's a
blocking this really fine line between
what you can believe and what what you
take on faith and I think that's
fascinating about about it the to
practice homeopathy in a place like
Haiti where where medicine and the plant
medicine tradition and also sort of the
overall envelope of reality is different
really really set me questioning anew I
guess the boundaries between the there's
supposedly possible and the impossible
right after right after being there I
had to fly straight to San Francisco for
a bunch of readings and I'm at one of
them
somebody got beaten up in in Oakland and
San Francisco it seemed like occupy was
breaking down in a really violent way
like a lot of people were like
physically beating each other up people
who had been working alongside each
other very very closely before I don't
know if any of you like we're in that
part of the world are in that experience
but I hadn't been there I had just come
from I had been I had been part of
Occupy New York but I come from a
completely disoriented other world I
remember going to rainbow grocery this
giant amazing collectively run health
food store in San Francisco that's like
it's like it's paradise had a health
food store eating this and um to go from
to go from the kind of food scarcity
that that you get accustomed to and the
kind of marketplace that you
accustomed to in Haiti to that kind of
plenty it was like I think I like had an
aneurysm or something and then
everybody's beating each other so I kind
of had a nervous breakdown and I was
like almost out of money that I went
down to the Los Angeles and I checked
into this really scuzzy motel and I all
I could do read I'm like a consent wall
and I was really really really in
despair and I don't even it's really
hard to explain why I was like there was
something about a a cascade of events
that with there was the basis was so
extreme that I just couldn't integrate
it do you know to you I don't know if
you've ever like come to a moment like
that in your life where you just get
full and you're like afraid you just
don't want anything else to happen for a
while and you just need for nothing to
happen until you can have something
happen again that was like really scary
for me when that happened because I
really really all I wanted to do was
nothing like oh really I just wanted to
look at the wall and I could sometimes
read Emily to consume which was great
but the motel was kind of expensive and
I couldn't stay there forever and
I started I started saying abracadabra
to myself I don't know then I mean you
guys are familiar with the word
abracadabra I guess from Lee cartoons
magic like I had I had picked up a book
a kind of cheesy book like sort of
Caribbean magic techniques but it's sort
of a more of like a touristy book in
French and it it had abracadabra in it
and I became really really drawn to it
and I started I started using it I was
like a psychic shizzle
and so I would say it to myself
Albert Cadabra abracadabra dub abracada
abracadabra cup a rock a bra and I would
do that over and over again and whenever
I was like like flipping out it would
calm me down it was like it really was
like some kind of like drill bit for my
brain
it's kind of embarrassing but I have to
tell you because that's how that's how
this came about
ancient evenings is a bad novel by
Norman Mailer everybody like you you've
read it Oh will you please would you
describe it sure it's a puffin cosmic
Oriya about this it's like an Egyptian
Fantasia that's a minute and symbology
and there's a prince
I only read like 40 pages I just
remember like a lot of scary
yeah after it like after my season with
abracadabra I come back to New York and
I was kind of freaked out I was still in
that state where I didn't want anything
to happen so I was living nocturnally
because I didn't I I couldn't talk to
anyone or do anything and I watched
Breaking Bad and and but and I was
reading a lot of sacred texts and and
what I what I noticed when I read them
was that it makes it was like it was as
though they made me they changed my
auric field or something they made me
better even though I I had no context to
understand
like you know I would read like the Guru
Granth sadly which is the one of the
seek seek tomes really foundational
texts and I don't know anything about
seek them even though I have a seat
uncle I don't know anything about the
the religion or culture I'm not a
scholar of it but just reading the text
itself was this incredible believe it it
gave me the feeling of health one that
hadn't experienced in a long time and I
I started to formulate this idea a way
of keeping the Sabbath a way of trying
to find rabbi rinds that's I mean that's
a joke but it's it's a true joke a way
of like putting my beard on and I'm
trying to trying to use my alienation as
a means toward hospitality this is
making any sense but you know when you
feel like a complete you feel like a
monster you feel like a werewolf or you
feel like a freak or something like
you're not fit for human consumption
I'm sure at least one person in this
room other than me knows what that feels
like okay great
like you like the last thing you can
think of is like being in a room with
people it's like you it's like you you
are like devouring yourself you're like
Quasimodo or whatever and you know I
feel like knows what that's like these
days and I just I had I had make I had
to cut carve away between that feeling
and and hospitality because I knew for a
fact that was not the only person in New
York City filled with dread and I was
thinking a lot at that time about what
what a great city is
what a city of legend is what what the
ancient cities of my dreams are and and
I started thinking about how New York
might be spoken ever thought of in a
thousand years or 2,000 years and and
this process of thinking and reading
foundational texts of religions about
which I knew very little and also
reading a lot of creation stories helped
return me to
poetry's place at the beginning at
cultures you know because I agree I've
grown up saturated with the sense that
I'm at the end whatever and that's I
feel like as a poet that's not at all
where I belong like poetry poetry
happens at the beginning of things and
you know that's like Freud phrase that
you know wherever he when a poet had
been there before him a lot a lot like
you know the space of poetry and the the
space both of the lyric and the epic is
the beginning things it's been like five
hours so so I decided I need to I need
to rhythmic eyes this need to turn
alienation into hospitality so I need to
make it every week and I need to make it
every week for long enough that like the
effect can actually take so I decided
fifteen weeks and it was the the timing
was perfect because the 21st of December
2012 when the world was supposed to end
remember I happen to be a Friday so the
all the dates work perfectly so it was
15 Fridays
to like lead us out to the
and the world or whatever and but the
whole point of it was to initiate a
sense of beginning in me and in the
group that I would be reading with and
my thought was we would read we would
read text with absolutely no context and
no preparation because the great gift it
seems to me of the Internet
theologically speaking is that we get to
read things that formerly you'd have to
be like a very high initiative I mean in
the inner inner sanctum of a given
tradition to have the right unit to look
at some of these books let alone to read
them and so this takes me back to that
pond symbol like there's a violence to
this like I I know that there's a side
of this kind of ransacking of the the
world heritage of theological text that
is completely irreligious very American
you know like quick kwi K or something
fast food short-circuit religion and yet
I also felt like for me it was the only
thing exhilarating me about the Internet
at that time just making any sense do
people need like a cider break or like a
chocolate-covered pretzel I wish I could
like I know the one thing about ancient
evenings that there's lots of food and
lots of alcohol so I'm like I'm really
really worried it's warm in here but I
swear I'm almost almost done telling the
story
so we have like a a dinner of Preedy
dinner with vodka and pickles and there
was this triangular mirror which you can
see in the back and and we did
abracadabra together and and that was
the first ancient evenings it was held
at a gallery in New York called to a 208
Bowery and the curators were put there
to let me use his face for free and
every week every week we would read
something not necessarily technically
ancient maybe something just culturally
you know or or something yeah or
something that had a kind of strangeness
to it so and that you know during that
time Hurricane sandy happened so because
the structure of ancient evening to a
stone was so generous in time we were
able to we were able to kind of be a
space that was healing for people doing
really really direct hardcore outreach
and to people trapped in public housing
filled with mosquitoes and getting no
food in the blackout darkness things
like that it became there was something
about the rhythm of the space that
became a little bit actually sanctuary
like and and we had guests come
let me tell you the guests were CI
Conrad Tony torn the after Joshua Cohen
Wang Kestenbaum and Eileen miles so they
came on different days and they would
they would lead us in a kind of homily
or whatever and the way that the way
that it worked was we've read the thing
whatever it was allowed and everybody
who reads so we all had to get used to
the sound of our own voices and people
can mispronounce things and usually we
would read something twice which if
you've ever done it it's kind of it
makes you kind of stoned like you can't
believe it's it's not an organ it's not
a way that we're used to reading these
days with our voices allowed but that is
what they do and like synagogue in
church right they read they just read
the Bible over and over again so I just
wanted to see if we if we could just
apply that to anything and and then
after the reading we would write and
there'd be so but once the reading was
done there would be no talking and we
would just immediately start writing
sometimes I play music and then after
the period of writing was done everybody
would read within is written and they
would and the rule was that you couldn't
say anything about anything you just
read it and then the next person would
read so and this created something
really really electric because sometimes
you really want
or you know whatever but there was no
work shopping and no workshop speech
allowed within this literally none and
but but there was like a Google Group so
people can talk to each other about each
other's work outside of that space but
within the space all we were there to do
was drink and eat and read and write and
that's what we did and then like in
between like in the breaks we talked to
each other but that was it but strangely
it created like this crazy bond of trust
and people started writing unbelievable
things really really amazing things it
seemed to unblock people it kind of
blocked me but that doesn't matter
anyway at the end so on December 21st
2012 vanity and a band and lots of
people came and read and performed and
the painter Nicole Eisenman was there
and because she's such a fast artist she
she painted this painting I think like
within a month or something and it's
already hanging in the expert museum art
she's lightning fast but this is a this
is Nicole's I have an imaginative
rendition of the December 21st
combination party of the first ancient
things and there was indeed there were
indeed performers like this and don't
remember somebody being naked but it
might have happened but anyway that's
that's the painting and for round 2 the
second year in 2013 our guests were Jami
Attenberg Timothy Donnelly Chris Krauss
been larger Jerry G O'Brien Justin
Taylor and nboyer and with too many
guests but they were so great so it was
it was impossible not to have them the
problem with having some
guests I learned is that like we didn't
get to develop that trust and that
rhythm that had really really become
strong in the first round and forgetting
to say something very very important oh
and this one this one took place in the
page poetry parlor in in New York and
the the final the culmination of that
was a lecture by one of our students a
Jacqueline du Lieber who is a poet and
she's a retired Chaucer professor and
her her pet interest in Chaucer had been
his the astrological dimension of the
Canterbury Tales and in fact of all of
his work and she's she's written five or
six books on Chaucer but she's not
written one about his astrology and so
she was on that and so the the closing
party that was really low-key and what
was really really wonderful about jack
clean and the last thing I wanted to say
about maybe the pedagogics pedagogical
thing around ancient evenings that I
that I feel really committed to is that
I think it's really really great to
teach poetry or to do writing in a room
full of people who aren't all the same
age and I'm really really really
committed to that and I have found that
just just between the experiences that I
had like teaching at Berkeley versus
teaching at the poetry project in New
York or poet's house in New York like I
thought I thought Berkeley was lovely
the students were all fantastic and it
was diverse it's a public
University and they were also brilliant
it was great but nothing can compare to
reading and writing in in a room when
you've got a bunch of people who are
doing different things and at different
stages in their lives and that's
something that I might be the thing I
cherish most about about this experience
I think that it I think that it made the
elders in the group feel young I think
that it made the younger people it gave
them an initiation into a sense of
language and a sense of experience that
that that was different from what they
could get in college because they were
always with people their own age and and
it also opened me up to something about
America which is that like I wish that
we I wish to people of different ages
were doing things together more it's
something that I miss maybe people have
big families do that all the time but I
have a very small family and so that's
not that's a good real laugh that's the
bomb in my in my life and something that
ancient evenings was fulfilling in a
kind of a churchy way too so the one
thing that I haven't spoken about yet is
the the economics but I feel like I want
to give a break I want to give you guys
is that okay to give a break for snacks
and and bathroom are settl slipping away
into the night
and and then we can come back and maybe
have a do do a little bit of question or
conversation if you want and then look
at the reading and do some write in that
good so great let's take a break